Traduttore: Paola Forti
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Buongiorno.
Per raccontarvi questa storia,
devo dirvi poche cose di me
e dell'azienda per cui lavoro.
Sono sicuro che quasi tutti voi
avete sentito parlare del gruppo Enel,
non so quanti di voi sappiano che
il gruppo Enel è, per valore di borsa,
l'azienda elettrica più importante
al mondo.
Sapete che siamo nella generazione,
nella distribuzione e nella vendita
di energia elettrica.
E, nella generazione, io mi sono
occupato negli ultimi tre anni
di generazione da fonti rinnovabili
con Enel Green Power.
Ed Enel Green Power è il leader mondiale
nello sviluppo, nella costruzione
e nella gestione di impianti che fanno
elettricità da fonti rinnovabili.
Quindi due grandi successi,
due grandi storie industriali italiane,
ma non sono qui per raccontarvi la storia
di queste due aziende, ovviamente.
Sono qua per raccontarvi
la storia di un fallimento
e di che cosa questo fallimento
ci ha insegnato.
Per farlo, state con me qualche minuto.
Vi devo spiegare come funziona
il settore elettrico.
E ve lo spiego andando a dividere
il mondo in tre categorie diverse.
La prima sono circa un miliardo e cento
milioni di persone, siete voi, siamo noi,
sono le persone che vivono
nel mondo di oggi,
negli Stati Uniti, in Europa,
che vivono nei cosiddetti mercati maturi
o mercati di sostituzione.
Perché sono mondi in cui c'è
forte sovra-capacità di generazione
e c'è una domanda che è sostanzialmente
piatta o in diminuzione
perché abbiamo imparato a consumare
di meno e a consumare meglio:
la cosiddetta efficienza energetica.
È un mondo in transizione.
Un mondo in transizione
verso la decarbonizzazione,
verso la generazione distribuita,
è un mondo di "prosumer"
che non è un tipo
di prosciutto. Siamo noi.
Noi possiamo, ora come ora,
produrre e consumare l'energia
che noi stessi produciamo.
L'energia avrà un costo
sempre minore nel futuro
e questo anche grazie alle rinnovabili.
Questo porterà un cambiamento profondo
perché vuol dire che ci sarà
una nuova ondata di elettrificazione,
sempre più il nostro mondo
diventerà elettrico,
e sempre più aziende come la mia
dovranno cambiare.
Vi faccio l'esempio dei veicoli elettrici.
I veicoli elettrici sono previsti avere
lo stesso costo di un veicolo
a combustione interna
entro i prossimi quattro anni
a parità di prestazione.
Si prevede che nei prossimi vent'anni
dei 100 milioni di veicoli
che vengono venduti ogni anno al mondo
circa il 50 per cento sarà elettrico.
Per me la macchina elettrica
non è un mezzo di locomozione,
per me che lavoro per un'azienda elettrica
la macchina elettrica
è una batteria su quattro ruote.
Questa batteria può fare tante cose,
ovviamente consuma energia, la immagazzina
ma può anche stabilizzare la rete,
quindi evitare che venga
costruita nuova generazione.
E lo fa attraverso delle colonnine
speciali di ricarica,
lo fa attraverso il software,
sì perché il software nel mio settore
diventerà un qualche cosa di essenziale,
di importante nel futuro.
Noi sempre di più diventeremo aziende
che gestiscono
sempre di meno i propri asset,
e sempre di più gli asset
di terzi, gli asset vostri.
Però ho parlato troppo del mercato nostro,
andiamo a vedere
gli altri due velocemente.
Il secondo è il cosiddetto
mercato dei paesi emergenti,
cioè i mercati che hanno bisogno
di tanta energia,
e qui ovviamente
il mix è molto più bilanciato,
costruiscono molto di più
impianti convenzionali,
costruiscono impianti rinnovabili
e costruiscono tanta
generazione distribuita.
E infine c'è un terzo mercato, un mercato
che nessuno di voi ha mai visto,
nessuno di voi probabilmente conosce,
è un mercato senza elettricità,
è un mercato buio
in cui un miliardo e 200 milioni
di persone si alzano la mattina
quando sorge il sole e vanno
a dormire quando il sole se ne va.
Questo mercato è più o meno uguale
alla popolazione che esisteva nel 1878
quando Edison ha inventato
la lampadina ad incandescenza,
quella che fino a ieri usavamo
in tutte le nostre case.
Io ho una grandissima fortuna,
io e altre circa 60 mila persone
lavorano per un'azienda che è cambiata
tantissimo negli ultimi anni,
e, certo, ovviamente andiamo al lavoro
per guadagnarci il nostro stipendio.
I miei figli, mia moglie,
tutta la mia famiglia
vivono di quello stipendio,
non siamo ricchi di famiglia.
Però abbiamo anche
un'altra grande fortuna.
Sapendo quello che sta succedendo
in questo mondo, nel nostro settore,
andiamo in ufficio pensando che possiamo
veramente cambiare il mondo.
E quindi ci siamo intestarditi,
abbiamo detto un miliardo e duecento
milioni di persone senza elettricità
non va bene, facciamo qualche cosa.
La cosa più ovvia per un'azienda
che è un'azienda tecnica
è stata quella di dire:
"Beh, la tecnologia,
la tecnologia cambierà il mondo,
noi siamo i più grandi,
i più bravi, i più forti
e quindi andiamo dove gli altri
hanno fallito, portiamo la tecnologia."
Abbiamo guardato il mondo
delle telecomunicazioni,
un grande successo, in particolare
dall'altra parte del Mediterraneo.
Siamo andati dove quasi la metà
di quel miliardo e 200 milioni di persone
vive senza elettricità.
Io non so quanti di voi sanno,
ma il 75 per cento e più
della popolazione subsahariana
ha un telefono cellulare.
Non hanno mai conosciuto
il telefono fisso,
c'è stato un salto di tecnologia.
Il telefono cellulare è diventato
estremamente importante.
Talmente importante che il cellulare
è uno strumento di sopravvivenza.
Senza il cellulare, non si fa business,
non si parla con le persone
che si conoscono,
ma in un continente così duro
e così difficile, si può anche morire.
Io non so quanti di voi sanno
che in Africa, in particolare in Kenya,
è stato inventato,
quasi direi più di 15 anni fa,
il mobile banking così come lo conosciamo.
Noi ora scambiamo denaro
tranquillamente sul telefonino.
Ma questo è stato inventato
in Kenya, tanto tempo fa.
Un'azienda chiamata SafariCom
si è accorta che c'era un problema.
Le banche non sono molto presenti
e allo stesso tempo,
in un continente
così difficile, così duro,
era necessario proteggere le persone,
che in altrimenti venivano derubate
se avevano grosse somme di denaro.
Quindi ha inventato
un sistema che tramite SMS,
e tutta una serie di agenti
sparsi sul territorio,
permettesse di scambiare il denaro.
Paypal, che probabilmente
tanti di voi utilizzano,
è stato inventato circa
una ventina d'anni fa in Sudafrica,
più o meno con lo stesso concetto.
Quindi, abbiamo detto tecnologia.
La tecnologia è quella
che risolverà il problema,
che darà la luce dove ci sta il buio.
E quindi abbiamo detto:
“Ok, è semplice, queste persone
hanno bisogno elettricità,
devono studiare
la sera, i bambini,
hanno bisogno di far girare
gli elettrodomestici,
con l'energia crescerà l'economia,
come ha fatto la telefonia,
vinceremo anche noi.
Sarà un grandissimo business,
faremo una cosa meravigliosa."
Quindi abbiamo iniziato a costruire
delle piccole, piccole reti isolate
con della tecnologia meravigliosa.
Ci siamo portati dietro
il contatore elettronico
in mezzo all'Africa,
perché eravamo pronti a fatturare
l'energia che avremmo venduto.
Guarda caso il business
non andava da nessuna parte,
non cresceva, non succedeva nulla,
sì, piccoli successi, qua e là.
Avevamo delle situazioni divertenti
dove il bambino studiava di più,
aveva fatto anzi grossi studi,
da questo punto di vista, grande successo.
Avevamo una situazione in cui l'economia
sì, leggermente migliorava,
ma nella realtà questa frotta di gente
che veniva non succedeva,
il business rimaneva li.
Allora abbiamo deciso
di riguardare la cosa, di ristudiarla,
e ci siamo accorti
di che cosa, delle cose ovvie.
perché noi ci eravamo
innamorati della soluzione,
non ci eravamo innamorati del problema.
Quindi siamo andati a vedere e ovviamente
la soluzione era tecnologicamente
forse troppo avanzata,
non aveva un gran senso.
Alla fine stendere fili
costa un sacco di soldi.
Il contatore elettronico
in mezzo all'Africa,
potete immaginare.
Il secondo punto è che
questa è gente che vive di agricoltura,
quindi continua ad alzarsi
la mattina presto,
a lavorare duro tutto il giorno,
a tornare la sera a casa
e poi andare a dormire presto.
La terza cosa, vi prego
non pensate che siamo sciocchi.
Vi ricordate Corrado Guzzanti
quando parlava di Internet,
e spiegava come Internet
era uno strumento meraviglioso,
aiutava a parlare a tutte le persone
in giro per il mondo
e faceva l'esempio di lui seduto a Roma
che parlava con l'aborigeno in Australia
e alla fine dello sketch diceva:
“Ma io a questo aborigeno,
che c’ho da dirgli?”
Ecco, era successa
la stessa cosa identica a noi.
Noi andavamo in questi villaggi,
la gente ci guardava, ci ringraziava,
ma poi ci diceva: “Ma io,
di questa elettricità, che ci devo fare?”
Era questa la situazione, avevamo fallito.
Ci eravamo concentrati
sulla cosa sbagliata.
La soluzione invece del problema.
E quindi?
Quindi i nostri giovani ragazzi
dello sviluppo, bianchi come il latte,
che escono dalla Bocconi, dal Politecnico,
che vengono anche
da grandi università americane,
si sono reimbarcati
e hanno riattraversato il Mediterraneo,
sono scesi, sono andati in Kenya,
sono andati in Tanzania,
sono andati in Etiopia,
e si sono riseduti con le persone
a cui avevamo costruito
queste meravigliose mini-reti.
Si sono seduti
accanto al capo del villaggio,
sotto l'albero principale,
quello che generalmente
domina questi villaggi,
e hanno iniziato a parlare con la gente.
Tutti in fila per raccontarci
la loro storia.
Tante storie.
Ve ne racconto una sulle tante
che abbiamo ascoltato.
C'è questa giovane ragazza,
una donna con due figli,
abbandonata dal marito,
che si è dovuta inventare imprenditrice.
Col telefono cellulare ha iniziato
a scambiare pesce essiccato,
siamo in Tanzania,
da un villaggio all'altro.
Con questo ha fatto un po’ di soldi
e con questi soldi ha comprato
due lampade solari.
Le lampade solari sono delle lampadine
con una piccola batteria
e un piccolo pannellino solare
che si carica durante il giorno
e fanno luce durante la notte.
Una più piccola l'ha messa
dentro casa, per uso domestico,
la seconda, un po' più grande,
l'ha messa invece fuori
per illuminare la strada.
Sì, perché il problema vero è la sicurezza
e quindi l'energia serve
per fare calore, per dare sicurezza.
La lampada solare è più che sufficiente
in questo momento,
nella situazione in cui siamo,
perché serve per ricaricare il cellulare,
che è fonte di vita, come abbiamo detto,
e sicurezza pure quello.
Insomma, l'energia,
di per sé, non crea sviluppo.
La tecnologia non è innovazione.
Innovazione è una parola
estremamente abusata.
La usiamo tantissimo in economia,
la usiamo tantissimo in politica,
la usiamo tutti i giorni,
ormai è dovunque.
Io non so quanti di voi sanno
che la parola innovazione
viene dalla botanica.
Significa germoglio, significa ramo nuovo.
E quindi il processo
innovativo, per avvenire,
ha bisogno di un terreno fertile,
ha bisogno di radici profonde,
ha bisogno di una pianta viva.
C'è un articolo meraviglioso
di Luigino Bruni
che vi consiglio di andare a leggere,
che parla appunto di come l'innovazione
possa essere accostata alla botanica
e ci dice che il contadino,
(il contadino potrebbe
essere la tecnologia)
è sì importante il lavoro
del contadino, la pazienza,
le mani del contadino aiutano
il germoglio a fiorire,
ma non possono crearlo.
Per far sì che l'innovazione vada avanti,
cresca effettivamente
c'è bisogno che la pianta
sia una pianta forte
e quindi bisogna arricchire la terra,
bisogna proteggere le piante deboli
e bisogna piantare
tante altre piante intorno.
Ecco, con questa idea in testa
abbiamo reinventato un progetto,
abbiamo completamente cambiato l'approccio
al problema del miliardo
e 200 milioni di persone senza luce
e abbiamo riattraversato
il Mediterraneo e siamo ripartiti.
Siamo ripartiti convinti che dovevamo
risolverlo in maniera diversa il problema.
Quindi ci siamo rivolti a chi
ci potesse dare una mano,
a chi ci potesse aiutare a creare
l'imprenditore del settore elettrico
del futuro in Africa.
Abbiamo iniziato a formare
una serie di persone
perché in questo caso siamo partiti
da un problema vero,
che è la migrazione per povertà,
la migrazione che porta
tutte queste persone
dal continente africano
all'Europa ricca, all'Italia ricca,
che si vede così presente
anche in questa città,
e abbiamo iniziato a cercare persone
che volontariamente volessero
diventare imprenditori.
Li abbiamo formati,
li aiutiamo a tornare a casa,
gli diamo un piccolo capitale,
gli diamo il materiale che gli serve
e li aiutiamo, li seguiamo
per avviare la loro attività.
Siamo perfettamente coscienti
che sono solo germogli,
sono piantine, piantine deboli.
Soltanto da alcune di queste
nascerà un albero forte,
ma dei frutti che faranno
ne beneficeremo tutti.
Attenzione però,
abbiamo necessità tutti noi di aiutarli,
perché le persone povere, gli esclusi,
perché possano essere veramente
motore di cambiamento del posto,
della loro terra, del paese in cui vivono
hanno bisogno dell'aiuto di tutti noi.
Perché soltanto con il nostro supporto,
progetti imprenditoriali possono
essere costruiti in maniera tale
che non guardino al passato,
come dice Bruni,
per ricercare garanzie di ieri,
ma guardino al futuro,
per ricercare garanzie del domani,
di progetti che ancora non esistono,
ma che potrebbero esistere,
se soltanto noi li iniziamo a vedere,
se soltanto noi li incoraggiamo
e li supportiamo.
Io ho viaggiato tanto per lavoro,
sono stato spessissimo in Africa.
Una cosa che è veramente bella è
che, quando tu atterri la mattina,
distrutto e vuoi andare
nel tuo albergo a riposare,
farti una doccia,
stai per ore in mezzo al traffico,
un traffico caotico,
anche per fare quattro chilometri
ci metti cinque ore,
e vedi un sacco di gente
che esce fuori da queste,
spesso, baraccopoli
vestiti con l'unico abito buono
che hanno e vanno a lavorare.
Perché il lavoro, ovviamente, ci nobilita,
ci dà la possibilità di fare tante cose
che altrimenti non potremmo fare.
Vedi tutti questi ragazzi che escono da lì
e sei cosciente che escono da lì
pensando che un giorno
in quelle baracche non ci torneranno.
Ecco, da un fallimento totale
siamo arrivati a una situazione
in cui, invece, abbiamo capito.
Da quello è nato un progetto
che noi riteniamo meraviglioso.
Così come nei mercati maturi,
le grandi dorsali elettriche
sono nate dall'aggregazione
di piccoli impianti isolati,
noi pensiamo che da questi
piccoli imprenditori di oggi
possa nascere lo sviluppo sostenibile
del futuro di quel continente.
Anche questo è Enel.
Grazie.
(Applausi)